foreign
comes from Brian in Nebraska my wife and
I live in Nebraska she's graduating from
dental school and we are expecting our
first child in may as well the only debt
we will have is a combined three hundred
thousand dollars in student loan debt
once she is done with school and a
mortgage of a hundred and eighty
thousand with forty to sixty thousand in
equity I currently make sixty two
thousand a year as an architect she has
a job offer in Memphis Tennessee to
teach as a professor for 160 000 or work
in Nebraska for 100 to 125 000 a year we
do we move to Memphis Tennessee with a
newborn where she can make more money
and we can sell the house to put our
Equity to pay our student loans or stay
in Nebraska to continue paying down debt
and have a community that is able to
help with the baby
well the first thing that struck me is
only three hundred thousand dollars
we only have three hundred thousand it's
not five hundred thousand it's only
three hundred oh my God
yeah the other thing that's interesting
to me is she's graduating from dental
school which that seems to be where the
debt's coming from but then she's going
to be a professor well there's a dental
college in Memphis okay I'll be Teaching
Ministry but do you think it's better to
to start out being a dentist and get
real world experience before teaching
yeah it's obviously not necessary I mean
there's even professors that you have
that had Real World Experience doing
anything except being a professor I mean
that seems like the best route I also
just wonder too like if she became an
actual dentist could she make more money
and knock that debt out quicker he's
saying she's got a hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars really first year
out 100 a quarter on dentist is about
right
I'm a little shocked at how high the
professor's score is that's a pretty
score 106. now and the question is too
okay so if you move down there and you
don't make at least 62 this is not an
upgrade
um
yep he's got to get a job making 62 or
more as an architect in Memphis well
that that also
a little low for an architect right it
does yeah
yeah there's a lot of questions on this
yeah so
all right let's just let's throw some
assumptions on there so we can answer it
let's say
that you moved to Memphis and you made
80 as an architect and she made
160. okay and you live there three or
four or five years and you clean up your
dad gum mess that you've made only 300
000 in debt right
um did he say how much Equity 40 to 60
in equity yeah not much okay so that's
not going to move the needle the big
thing that moves the needle is the
income difference
um
foreign
or
we change jobs as an architect in
Nebraska and make more money and she
gets a better job than she's been
offered so far as a dentist and makes
150 in Nebraska if she can make 150 and
he can make 80 and you hate the idea of
Memphis yeah instead of Nebraska then I
would stay and it takes you another
what six months to a year to get out of
debt you know if you do that
um but I you you seem to be underpaid
right right for your I mean if you have
a four-year degree in architecture and
you're making 62. I got a problem okay
period let's just say that number two
125 is a little low but not super bad
for a first time out out of the gate
dentist that's not bad at all
um
I I kind of think I'm hearing Down Under
that last sentence
uh have Community that's able to help
with a baby do I move away from
everything that I know my family my
roots my church
well another factor to consider is the
fact that like I don't know what that
Community is going to do like how much
they're going to help but but there's
daycare costs as well if you move to
Memphis maybe maybe in Nebraska you have
a grandma who's planning on taking care
of the baby and in Memphis you're going
to have to pay for full-time daycare so
even in that equation just making sure
to factor you've got to run that in
there too so
um
if you maximized
your income in both locations it sounds
like Memphis gets you out of debt a year
sooner no one says you have to live
there the rest of your life it's not
required
uh you could go work there three or four
years and then move
back to Nebraska that would be fine if
you hate it
um you could look at it as an adventure
you know it's not a uh it's not a
permanent decision forever and ever I
mean you could look at it as an
adventure and go do that like for
instance these people that are
contractors with the military and they
go to Dubai for a year and make 6X what
they would have made in the states and
pay off everything and they kept
basically give up a year and they have a
little adventure and Dubai and go do it
and you know or whatever and there's a
in the sandbox one way or another and
there's people doing that and uh that's
that huge but it's a matter of looking
at it I think the I'm going to be away
from community and everything that I
know
has a rest of your life feel to it that
isn't required
as far as I know you can still
um
uh
they still allow you to leave Memphis
once you move there
true
I mean but I'm also thinking like
personally she is graduating from dental
school so there's going to be a huge lab
change just in going from being a
full-time student to working and then
she just had a baby she's got a newborn
so even just man the first year
postpartum I would not have been super
excited about an adventure across
country and moving away from family so
there's also just the emotional aspect
of like what does she really want like
what what is her capacity you know we're
going to Minneapolis tomorrow night okay
and um I've got friends from that grew
up in Minneapolis they were born and
bred there everything they knew was
there and um at 50 something years old
they said I'm tired of being cold I'm
leaving
and they moved to Nashville
and they lived down the street from us
you know and they're they're sweet
people they go back to Minneapolis
occasionally see their friends but they
were tired of it and you may be tired of
Nebraska I don't know but it doesn't say
that here true what seems to be between
the lines here is you would hate leaving
Nebraska and the only reason you'll be
doing it would be for a little extra
money and I would challenge you instead
to go maximize your incomes where you
are and stay 100 yeah and if it takes
you one year longer to get out of debt
by doing that but don't stay there and
make 62 and 100 which is more than which
is all she could have made that much by
herself because you two both minimized
the crap if you make 60 and she makes
100 that's 162 she got opportunity to
make 160 by herself in Memphis that's
not okay so if you're going to stay in
Nebraska you need to go up your game yes
somewhat it doesn't have to be as high
as the Memphis and the Memphis steel
does not work at all dude if you don't
get an architectural job there making
more than you make now right well and
I'd also be curious about cost of living
like it seems like I mean I'm not super
familiar with Nebraska but it seems like
a deep cheaper to live there versus in
Memphis but probably but Memphis is not
that high but also just make sure to
compare that because even the equity you
have in your house 40 to 60 000 it's not
that much money and so just make sure
you compare the the just the cost of
living the cost of daycare all of that
in fact or all that into consideration
because so here's a mistake that people
make in their logic on this and this is
the the subject in general do I move for
a job
it it's as if they're doing is if are am
I doing something wrong if I don't take
a job in a place I hate because it pays
more
no you're not
careers are personal things
personal finance is first personal and
then it's Finance
and and so you know if you I'll give you
an example okay people told us with the
with the Dave Ramsey Show in the old
days that it will never be a big radio
show if we don't move to LA or New York
and I'm like I've like visiting LA or
New York for about
48 hours and then I'm ready to leave the
chances of me living there is precisely
zero
and if that means that the Dave Ramsey
show is never a big deal because I
refuse to locate in one of those two
cities
um then it won't be now it turns out
that we're the second largest Talk Radio
in America today so those people that
said that didn't know what they were
talking about thank goodness but I made
the choice quality of life Nashville
versus those two places oh Dad Gum no
question I'm chuckling a little bit
inside trying to picture you living in
L.A or New York bringing redneck radio
to the big city
well we are broadcasting both of them
thank you very much but yeah